[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Darmanin vos servic ont-ils
peur du contrôle citoyen sur les
élections gravé auparavant dans le Code
électoral l'annexion des listes de
procuration au procès verbaux de chaque
vote est supprimé par le décret du 11
mars
2021 celui du 22 décembre confirme que
ces listes restent en mairie enfin la
circulaire du 31 décembre à 4 mois de la
présidentielle et 5 mois des
législatives ordonne au maire de ne plus
annexer ses listes au PV cet
enchaînement méticuleux rend
techniquement impossible la vérification
d'un scrutin car la préfecture n'est
plus le lieu centralisateur en 10 jours
délai imparti pour faire un recours
prendre rendez-vous dans les 22 mairies
de ma circonscription est quasi
impossible pour celle composé de
centaines de communes cela relève du
miracle une capacité som toute peu
commune chez les candidats le matériel
peut toujours être rapatrié au Conseil
constitutionnel sur demande d'un avocat
qu'il s'agit de payer 3000 € pour y
faire ce qui se faisait gratuitement en
préfecture
ensuite venir consulter le tout à Paris
et ce en une demi-journée une gageure
monsieur Darmanin pourtant nous l'avons
fait par ma circonscription de
charante sur 134 procurations
manuscrites 64 n'existait pas le
résultat s'étant joué à 24 voix cela
laisse pour le moins perplexe monsieur
le ministre des personnes malhonnêtes en
non profité pour tricher triche en
charante erreur de bulletin dans les
bureaux de la riège profession de fois
non distribué un peu partout bref
comment comptez-vous corriger le tir aux
élections européennes de juin afin
d'éradiquer ces pratiques qui abîment un
peu notre démocra merci la parole est à
Gérald armanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des
[Applaudissements]
outres merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député permettez-moi d'abord
de dire que je n'ai pas tout à fait
compris votre question parce que s'il y
a 64 erreurs de procuration et que vous
avez gagné à 24 voix je me pose du coup
la la question
la la présence dans l'hémicycle bon mais
cependant la question que vous posez
c'est celle de d'accès d'accès au
documents d'accès d'accès aux documents
électoraux qui sont effectivement
lorsqu'on peut les vérifier la la la la
preuve que le scrutin s'est passé dans
bonne possibilité et de pouvoir
contester le cas échéant d'abord votre
question monsieur le député si je peux
me permettre un peu étonnante vous ne
faites pas manifestement confiance au
maire de votre circonscription puisque
c'est bien sur la base de la mairie sur
la base de la mairie monsieur le député
que non seulement on tient des listes
électorales mais qu'on les garde par de
vers soi pour pouvoir permettre au 48h
la possibilité de vérification je ne
saurais trop vous recommettre de d'avoir
confiance dans les maires de votre
circonscription et par ailleurs qui
agissent non pas en tant qu'élu mais qui
agissent en tant que représentant de
l'État deuxièmement vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'être tout seul le celui qui va
voir les listes électorales vous pouvez
évidemment déléguer des personnes c'est
tout à fait possible et c'est moins
complexe que lorsqu'il fallait aller en
moins de 48 he au centre-ville de la
préfecture euh parce qu'effectivement là
les choses étaient parfois différentes
où on se bataillait pour récupérer
chacun l' vécu sans doute ces sujets
électoraux en moins de 48 he
troisièmement vous pouvez toujours
photographier ces listes électorales
quatrièmement vous avez tout à fait le
droit en effet de pouvoir en demander
une ampliation euh ces documents ces
documents monsieur le député ont tous
été validés par le Conseil d'État qui
juge de l'élection merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre